the work is done
i won
I'm about to do I'm gonna enjoy
very very much
[Music]
tickets on sale now hi everyone its
charlie we got brand-new Avengers
endgame footage to breakdown you thought
that special look teaser was the end of
it they're going on Kimmel all of next
week they're taking over that TV show so
we're probably gonna get even more
footage next week but right after they
drop that special look last night ESPN
dropped a brand new TV spot with a bunch
of new footage and it just shows Captain
Marvel after the events of the Captain
Marvel post-credits scene you get a
whole bunch of new dialogues we'll break
it down it also puts some of the other
scenes that we've seen in the other
trailers into context so we have a
better sense for the timeline especially
early in the movie we're only a couple
weeks away from it hitting theaters so
of course I'll keep doing the IMAX
ticket giveaway every week until we get
there so all you have to do to enter
that is be a subscriber and leave your
favorite moment from the trailer on the
video congratulations to everyone that
was able to score tickets to when they
drop that special look that was the
whole reason for that tickets on sale
now the movie broke all kinds of ticket
sales records but the voice over front
Thanos in this footage is a little
tongue-in-cheek the way that they use it
the work is done like building up to
this big final act of The Avengers
infinity saga now we the audience can
enjoy what they're about to do very very
much even though in the context of this
is coming from some different point in
the film with fan oohs talking to the
Avengers either during their first
attempted rematch or during the later
one that we see at the Avengers base
missed all that rubble but he says the
work is done I won talking about the
events of Avengers infinity war in the
snap what I'm about to do I'm gonna
enjoy it very very much there was a
description of the movie a little while
ago that implied that there would be a
greater threat that would surface during
avengers endgame everyone was thinking
that might be another villain from the
comics it still seems like they're
pitching Thanos is the main villain of
this movie because the Avengers are
trying to fix everything in Thanos is
trying to stop them from fixing
everything and undoing the snap but if
the movies gonna be three hours long
that is so much plot so I would not be
surprised if they did tease some sort of
other villain but for now we'll just
assume that the a nose is still the main
villain of the movie based on the way
that they're marketing it but they are
very misleading in the way that they
market their films so take all this
footage with a grain of salt but you
start with the very ominous shots of
Manhattan the Statue of Liberty very
ominous Mets Stadium where it looks like
there's just nobody left all these cars
that are abandoned
the way to show you where the world's at
post snap whether it's a couple weeks
after the snap or a couple months you
see the dust at marvel studios 10-year
anniversary logo it'll be interesting to
see what they changed that logo to next
year because it'll be 11 years but then
you see Captain Marvel in the Avengers
base after she's answered her page after
the events of the Captain Marvel
post-credits scene but she shows up at
the Avengers base like a ninja looking
for Nick Fury where's fury she's wearing
the same outfit that she had on in that
Thor seen from the previous trailer so
she's not wearing the gold shouldered
armor anymore she's taken that off and
it seems like it's been a little while
since the events of that post-credits
scene CinemaCon is happening right now
they showed off about 5 minutes of the
movie during that in its different
footage but it's basically the same
scene that they showed off at the
private Disney investors meeting a
couple weeks ago I already did a video
about that the 5 minutes of footage is
basically them here in this moment then
them arguing the Thor scene and that it
ends with this moment with them on the
guardianship but here in this scene you
see Captain Marvel Captain America and
Rhodey in that same room from the
Captain Marvel post-credit scene where
they were using Iron Man's computers to
try and find out who got snapped by
Thanos and who's still alive you can see
the number counter going above 3 billion
that's you know about half the people on
the planet which makes sense because
Stannis was snapping half of all living
things in the universe so half of all
animals half of all people half of all
the aliens on the other planets you
notice the flaw in their system when you
think about the other scene from the
last trailer with banner looking at
those displays because the computers
seem like they're just searching for
signs of people or sightings because the
computer thinks that Ant Man got snapped
but that's only because it can't detect
him when he's in the quantum realm which
it seems like he still is when this
scene of banner staring at the displays
is happening so this is a little bit
earlier in the film in this scene you
notice that Erik Selvig got snapped we
watched Falcon turn to dust at the end
of infinity war there's no mystery there
the display start changing you see the
wasp we also watched her turn to dust
during the ant-man in the wasp
post-credits scene Scarlet Witch we also
watched turn to dust at the end of
infinity war I saw a lot of weird
questions in my timeline yesterday about
why the text underneath their readouts
is facing us when we the audience are
watching this from the other side of the
display so the text should actually be
backwards to us but I think that's just
a trailer
we're Marvel wants you to be able to
clearly read the names easily for people
that aren't really familiar with these
characters because remember they're
marketing the movie to people like your
mom your grandma they want everybody on
the planet to see this movie if you're a
big comic book fan they would not need
to put their names under those readouts
they could just put the picture up and
you would know exactly who that person
is pretty reasonable to assume that this
Thor scene of him in the hoodie just
sitting there really pensive just really
antsy about wanting to do something is
from that same part of the movie now
that we have a little more context about
what the scenes are when Captain Marvel
arrives the clothes that he's wearing
before they bore the guardianship the
scene that they showed up at CinemaCon
is basically Captain Marvel arguing with
them about what they're gonna do next
and then rody trying to explain to her
how they do things as a team you also
get to hear Captain America swear but
nobody pipes up language because I've
easily spent to be this big rally moment
but it's super early in the film and
it's before they're unsuccessful first
attempt at a rematch Captain Marvel is
the one who immediately wants to turn
right back around and go kill thanos
nebula is the one that gives them the
location of his special farm rocket
gives them the idea that that's the part
of the galaxy that he might be in he
said that they detected a very specific
energy signature when Thanos snapped
everyone and they detected it again in a
different part of the galaxy that means
that Thanos has used the gauntlet again
all six Infinity stones in combination
to create this special farm-like planet
he probably just tear forms the planet
using the Infinity Gauntlet
and that's why rocket is able to detect
him like oh this is where he is in this
region nebula is the one that says very
specifically this is the exact planet
that he's on she tells a story about
when she was a little girl how Fanus
would keep speaking of this special farm
that they would go to a special place
when all their quote unquote work was
done Captain Marvel is like the most
gung-ho character in this conversation
that they're having she's like I'm gonna
go kill him right now
let's go kill thanos banner says we go
in we go in short-handed and she says
well this time you have me that's why
things are different
Captain Marvel talks about usually
working alone like she's been working
alone for mostly the last 20 years
because she's so powerful so the way
they sort of balance that out with the
Avengers is that Rhodey says we usually
do things as a team which I also think
is built into the core theme
of the movie like I said in my last
video in all the different footage that
we've seen so far what is the one thing
that we have not gotten yet all six
original Avengers standing together in
frame in any of the footage what was one
of the themes of the last Avengers movie
and infinity war had they all worked
together they might have been able to
get the gauntlet off of Thanos and
prevent the snap so you can kind of see
the arc of things through the film
Captain America and Iron Man have to
make nice do you trust me yes everybody
has to come back together put their
differences aside and work as a team to
defeat Thanos and fix the universe so
the sort of setting that up with this
Captain Marvel scene Captain Marvel kind
of tries to do things by herself they go
in short-handed they're unsuccessful
later in the film like this scene here
where they're all walking towards Thanos
implies that there's more of them
working together but even then it's hard
to tell what else is going on because
you don't see the rest of the frame so
it's hard to tell whether or not Hulk is
behind them but we do know that the
other Avengers are in and around that
base but remember it's a three-hour
movie so they defeat Thanos there's
probably gonna be a whole bunch of other
stuff that they have to do after that in
pursuit of trying to fix the universe
and bring all those dusted people back
in one way or another you get that same
shot at Thanos as mothership the
sanctuary 2 with the smaller drop ships
orbiting around it above what looks like
a devastated planet this does not look
like Titan which had a reddish
atmosphere it doesn't look like Titan -
which Stannis is sitting on because that
had a blue looking atmosphere like
Earth's and it also doesn't look like
Morag the purple looking planet that the
benitar is jumping away from here we
don't know when this is happening but
for some reason it seems like they go
back to Morag during the movie the only
reason to go back there would be if it
has something to do with the Power Stone
because that's where Peter quill found
the Power Stone at the beginning of the
guardians of the galaxy movie there's a
brand new scene of Iron Man covering his
eyes because of a bright light that
seems like it's approaching maybe this
is them being rescued or them
approaching earth it just seems like
he's surprised and he just looks
absolutely terrible like he hasn't eaten
he hasn't slept in weeks there's a lot
of theories about he and nebula make it
back but because of the way he's hugging
pepper here when they get off of the
ship at the Avengers base it seems like
it's the first time he's seen her since
he left Earth in Avengers infinity war
my theory about pepper and the rescue
armor during the film is that she does
get to do some badass stuff wearing the
armor but it's largely support
during a big battle scene and she's only
on camera for a short bit like when she
wore the armor during Iron Man 3 she had
a really cool but short armor scene at
the beginning of Iron Man 3 then a
badass takedown scene at the end of the
movie so I'm just expecting a similar
amount of badassery from her during
avengers endgame but because you see
nebula and this other trailer footage
seemingly cannibalizing her mechanical
parts here while she and Iron Man
metaphorically engineer their escape
from the quote-unquote cave
Iron Man 1 style I think their rescue so
to speak is as simple as that
Iron Man cannibalizes his suit
technology and nebula uses her own parts
from her body to repair the guardianship
well enough to limp their way back to
earth or within range for someone else
to come tow them back one of the big
themes of the movie is whatever it takes
so it would be like chopping off your
arm to survive if you were trapped in a
life-or-death situation you get the
scene of Captain America black widow war
machine and banner outside the Avengers
base at night looking up in the sky I
think we can safely assume now that this
is the benitar arriving with Iron Man
and nebula you get the same scene of
Hawkeye running through those tunnels
with the explosion behind him I think
now because we've had footage that
seemed like the outriders are chasing
him through those tunnels the forearmed
doglike creatures that Thanos use during
Avengers infinity war that this chase
scene is happening underneath the
Avengers base and it's when Thanos comes
to destroy them after their first
unsuccessful attempt to go kill him
earlier in the movie based on all the
other footage that we got of them
fighting phantoms in this wreckage from
the last trailer this scene of Captain
America tightening his shield around his
arm clenching his teeth seems like it's
from the same battle at The Avengers
base he's wearing the same newer scale
armor from the comics but the frame cuts
off so high on his chest here that you
can't see the white star his Nomad armor
with the darkened star was just his old
Captain America Civil War armor that had
worn down from usage and battle damage
it seems like his newer scale armor is
just a redesigned polished version of
that made to look a little more
aggressive and also in the vein of his
comic book scale armor just like Iron
Man's new mark 85 is designed to look
like his classic gold comic book armor
now I know you're asking why is this
armor called the mark 85 when the
infinity war armor was the mark 50 what
happened to those other 34 armors the
really important thing about the
CinemaCon footage of Captain Marvel in
them arguing with Thor
what they're gonna go do next we should
go kill thanos let's do it is this the
ironman is not with them it seems like
when he nebula first come back and you
see him hug pepper they go off together
like he pieces out for a brief part of
the movie and during that period while
he's away from them that's when he
iterates a bunch of new different armors
you get a brand new scene of rody and
rocket getting caught in a giant
explosion inside the avengers base this
is probably when Thanos shows up in
attacks notice that the floor gives way
and they slide off we've never really
traveled all over the New Avengers base
but wherever they are here there's
something really big underneath this
level you get a brand new scene of them
approaching Thanos with a much cleaner
shot of his giant double bladed sword in
the ground with Thanos sitting there in
his armor but not wearing his helmet
he's still a little blurry so it's hard
to tell if he's sitting there because
he's tired and they've already traded
blows or if he's just taunting them
waiting for them to show up so that they
can start the real fight like I said the
Avengers endgame cast is taking over
Jimmy Kimmel for most of next week so
there may be more footage more TV spots
more scenes that they release of course
I'll do videos for that the other really
really big thing that's happening is the
game of Thrones
as I'm posting this video is dropping in
10 days of course I'll be doing a whole
bunch of videos for that so leave all
your bonus video requests for Avengers
or anything else in the comments below
congratulations to the winner from my
last big Marvel video V Sam games please
email me on the about page of my channel
so I can get your details click here to
rewatch that avengers endgame
special.look trailer and all my easter
eggs
and click here to watch that new game of
thrones season 8 trailer thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]